vous ni moi ni cavalli ipa ghazaouet
masquer la bouche et thijs maturité
grâce mme brochet mais votre attention
s'il vous plaît ici moscou en direct de
la place rouge pour le défilé des
célébrations du 66e anniversaire de la
victoire met enfin à la grande guerre
patriotique
[Musique]
pour saluer le drapeau de la fédération
de russie est l'étendard de la victoire
garde à vous salut à gauche présentée au
[Musique]
la crasse et
muschick de soudeur de maintes fois sur
la place rouge vérifier drapeau national
de la fédération de russie aux pieds des
sandales en cinquième division u10a
devenu le symbole
ainsi pas de la victoire d'hier à la fin
de la 76e sur deux toiles réalisées milo
ah koon chemin puisqu'elle termine
nationale est écrasée de la victoire est
à nous aujourd'hui le drapeau les
taulards de la vidéo à vous porter par
les meilleurs des militaires ni le
rappeur france où les autres les
commandants max mara bof et alex et
autres
[Musique]
dès les premiers jours de la guerre des
centaines de milliers de volontaires
partir d'eau fournis défendre leur terre
natale contre les envahisseurs nazis
leur héroïsme et leur vaillance dont la
défense de brest
odessa sébastopol smolensk toul à
leningrad moscou stalingrad mirent fin
au projet de destruction réclère de
l'union soviétique
[Musique]
leurs noms sont inscrits pour toujours
dans la cause de la victoire grâce aux
efforts accomplis par les arrières par
leur labeur dévoués dans les délais les
plus brefs
il pu rétablir la production
industrielle et assurer
l'approvisionnement en armes et
équipements nécessaires à l'armée rouge
les héritiers des soldats de la victoire
et le peuple russe dans son ensemble
salut l'étendard de la victoire et les
vétérans de la grande guerre patriotique
libérèrent la patrie et les pays
d'europe de la peste brune
[Musique]
au repos
hugo
le défilé garde à vous salut à gauche
présenté à
[Musique]
blidge vraiment
les troupes prêts à défiler sont passés
en revue par le général d'armée sergueï
choïgou ministre de la défense de la
fédération de russie au son de la marche
militaire le général choïgou se dirige
vers le centre de la place rouge pour
entendre le compte rendu de l'état du
dispositif
[Musique]
monsieur le ministre de la défense
les troupes de la garnison de moscou
sont prêtes pour le défilé en l'honneur
du 66e anniversaire de la victoire
générale c'est le kof
[Musique]
j'aimais
le ministre de la défense commence le
passage en revue des troupes du défilé
[Musique]
mr nabarro messerli chez nous
le général sergueï choïgou va saluer les
troupes terrestres
[Musique]
le ministre de la défense adresse un
message de félicitations au trouvent
rassemblés sur la place rouge
[Musique]
ça sert
les effectifs des troupes terrestres
poursuivent le perfectionnement de leurs
aptitudes au combat ils s'instruisent
pour maîtriser les nouveaux types
d'armements et d'équipements militaires
et leurs modalités d'emploi les troupes
terrestres continue à jouer un rôle
majeur en matière de sécurité et de
défense des intérêts de la russie
[Musique]
c'est une mauvaise mesure la loi c'est
triste kadhafi n'est pas bienvenu que
c'est juste une manière
[Musique]
il
le ministre de la défense a salué les
forces aérospatiale les pilotes des
forces aérospatiale les militaires de la
défense anti aérienne et des troupes
spatiales au cours d'inspections
surprises et de leur mission de veille
permanente ont fait preuve d'un niveau
élevé de leur disponibilité à remplir
leur mission de défense de l'espace
aérien et extra atmosphérique du pays
[Musique]
m
bonjour
[Musique]
le ministre de la défense vient de
saluer les détachements du district
militaire ouest des unités de
transmission de la police militaire de
la garde nationale et du ministère des
situations d'urgence
[Musique]
c'est eux
parce que cette histoire ce n'est pas
bien
[Musique]
le ministre de la défense a salué en
mémoire de la victoire les détachements
des troupes aéroportées et des unités du
génie mme de défense nbc et de missiles
stratégiques
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le ministre de la défense a salué les
détachements de la marine le fsb service
fédéral de sécurité des troupes
ferroviaire des cosaques les femmes
militaires et des jeunes élèves des
écoles militaires souvorov nash imhoff
et des cadets de la marine ainsi que des
membres du mouvement de narnia
aujourd'hui ce sont plus de 12 mille
militaires qui participent aux défilés
le général sergueï choïgou a terminé de
passer leurs troupes en revue et va
rendre compte au président de la
fédération de russie commandant en chef
des forces armées russes l'admirent
petit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans le camp iguana camondo chi wah
rejoindre l'émission amis voici ce
qu'elle fêtera ses prouesses que basko
ce qu'on gagne zone à bord du bateau
ministre la baronnais de repos
[Musique]
chers citoyens de russie
chers anciens combattants camarades
soldats matelots sous-officiers
officiers mariniers camarades officiers
généraux amiraux bonne fête de la
victoire
cette fête de signifie qu'une
signification historique très importante
pour l'ensemble du monde constitue une
fête qui a été est et sera toujours pour
la russie pour notre peuple russe une
fête sacrée à juste titre c'est la
victoire sur cet ennemi qui a été le
nazisme et qui a laissé les marques pour
toutes les générations et nous vénérons
l'héroïsme de ce qu'ils ont vaincus
chers anciens combattants nous nous
inclinons devant votre force devant
votre vaillance votre cohésion et votre
amour de la patrie que vous avez montré
que ce n'est qu'ensemble que nous
pouvons parvenir à ce qui semblait
impossible
vous avez surmonté cet ennemi vous
l'avait vaincu vous avez était prêt à
sacrifier vos enfants tout ça pour
sauver la patrie et c'est une victoire
incontestable qui sera saluée dans les
siècles
cette date restera historique le 9 mai
1945 nous souviendrons toujours de
l'importance de cet exploit accompli par
le peuple soviétique dans les batailles
les plus décisives pour l'issue de la
guerre
notre peuple s'est montrée unie gym dans
cette voie d'abnégation de dévouement
est sur tous les fronts dans tous les
combats les plus âpres en sur terre en
mer dans les airs et en défendant cette
fois cette fois en la valeur de la terre
natale
que ce soit sur les marches de
l'arctique ou sur les marches des
montagnes du caucase sur le
franchissement des grande rivière du
lièvre du danube et c'est là le peuple
russe a défendu les populations civiles
a défendu les villes héroïque de moscou
et de saint-pétersbourg les dégradent à
l'époque de kiev de kertch stalingrad
smolensk nouveau re 6 et 7
ce qu aux ions entre le front et les
arrières ont apporté ce qu'il fallait
pour assurer cette victoire et les
usines de l'oral de sibérie ont
travaillé dans kazakhstan et dans
d'autres républiques d'asie centrale
les efforts ont continué au niveau
industriel et les peuples se sont prêts
se sont montrés prêts à verser leur sang
pour sauver la patrie
aujourd'hui nous rendons hommage et nous
exprimons notre gratitude à toute la
génération de ses héros de la guerre
nous garde en mémoire la vaillance et le
courage j'ai héros et il garde en
mémoire cette douleur qui ne passent pas
la douleur des camps de concentration la
douleur des villages détruits dans les
territoires occupés et nous garde en
mémoire tous ceux qui ont perdu la vie
dans cette
ça y est c'est la mémoire des fils et
filles des pères des mères et grands
parents dès mardi
des femmes des frères deux soeurs des
camarades de régiment des proches des
amis et nous gardons en mémoire ce qui
nous ont quittés je déclare une minute
de silence
chers amis cette année ça fait 80 ans
que cette guerre mondiale a commencé
cette grande guerre patriotique et le 22
juin 1941 est une des dates les plus
tragiques de l'histoire de la russie
l'ennemi a agressé notre terre il est
venu sur notre terre pour semer la
douleur la mort l'horreur et des
souffrances insupportables
il ne voulait pas seulement éliminé les
structures politiques le système
soviétique mais nous détruire détruire
en tant qu' en tant qu'etat en tant que
nation et effacés de la surface de la
terre cpt la russie et cette menace est
devenu a constitué un élan pour
l'ensemble de la population des peuples
de russie résister contre 7,7 et demi et
le peuple soviétique s'est levé s'est
souvenu de son serment et a libéré les
pays d'europe du joug nazi et en se
souvenant de la force et de la puissance
de notre armée et du courage de
l'abnégation des mères et des épouses
qui ont laissé partir ceux qui ne sont
pas toujours revenu mais cette mémoire
restera une autre esprit
au cours des siècles rendre hommage
aussi à tout le personnel médical qui a
sauvé les blessés et qui a fait tout son
possible sur le front pour sauver ceux
qui avaient été touchés
cette guerre qui a été la plus sanglante
qui a frappé aussi les jeunes
générations les succès m donc cette
guerre a porté de temps douleur tant de
malheurs qu'il est impossible de
justifier ou de pardonner ce qui s'était
laissé aller à vous donner cette
agression vous voyez ce régime d monstre
nazi prendre de l'ampleur au coeur de
l'europe avec l'antisémitisme la
xénophobie et tout cela devait être
arrêté il fallait mettre fin à cette
guerre et l'histoire nous oblige à tirer
des conclusions à tirer des leçons mais
nous constatons que tous ne sont pas
prêts à tirer cette conclusion et qui
veulent en à nouveau défendre cette
idéologie on voit la résurgence de
d'extrémistes et d'adeptes de cette
idéologie de volonté voit cette volonté
de réécrire l'histoire et les centaines
de milliers de morts sont ignorés par ce
genre aujourd'hui on sait que chaque
famille garde la mémoire de ceux qui
sont combattus la russie continue à
défendre le droit international et le
continuerons à défendre en même temps
nos intérêts nos intérêts nationaux
les vaillantes forces armées russes sont
prêtes à défendre la sécurité et les
intérêts de la russie en faveur du
développement de la prospérité des
familles et de nos vétérans leur destin
des exemples pour ligne et c'est d'un
modèle à suivre et que nous
vers lequel nous devons tendre et donc
jeunes aux affaires réussite future
saluons la gloire du peuple russe
heureuse fête de la victoire à tous quoi
à
[Musique]
le défilé carte vous paraît au défilé
pas de bataille on garder la distance
le premier bataillon tout droit les
autres à droite droite larmes sur
l'épaule à droite aliments qu'on avant
marche
c'est le début du défilé des troupes à
pied de défiler et placés sous les
ordres du général d'armée oleg salenko
[Musique]
sur la place rose les jeunes musiciens
de l'école d'humilier chrtr de musique
militaire du ministère russe de la
défense qui porte le nom de valeri
khalilov la compagnie d'honneur et sous
les ordres du colonel alexandre
guerassimova commandant l'école de
musique militaire
les jeunes musiciens de la compagne de
tambourin ouvre le défilé solennelle des
troupes mais donne le rythme et le pas
de marche aux unités qui défilent devant
les tribunes défilent les porte drapeaux
de l'étendard de la victoire du drapeau
national de la fédération de russie et
de l'étendard des forces armées russes
les porte drapeaux sont accompagnées de
la compagnie de la gare de donneurs de
sang 54e régiment autonome de commandes
manque le régiment dit preobrazhensky
[Musique]
la place vous accueillent les étendards
historique de combat des unités ayant
été décorés pendant la guerre de
l'oeuvre d'alexandre nevski les
héritiers de leurs exploits participe
aujourd'hui aux défilés dans le
détachement d'honneur à cette année nous
célébrons d'ailleurs les 800 ans de
chefs de guerre et défenseur de la
vieille russie
le prince alexandre nevsky c'est
maintenant au tour d'une compagnie de
l'école militaire sous vos ordres de
moscou de défiler devant les tribunes
sous le commandement du colonel igor
ekimov les élèves de l'école sont des
participants incontournable de défilé de
la victoire sur la place rouge
les élèves de l'école militaire seule
europe de la ville de trets rage
le détachement d'honneur et sur les
autres du colonel igor quezada hier en
1943 l'école accueilli ses premiers
élèves marqué par le destin des armes
il devint pour eux leur maison natale
est une école de vie
sur les pavés de la place rouge vous
voyez un détachement d'honneur et élèves
de l'école nakhimov de saint pétersbourg
sous les ordres du contre-amiral
alexandre pauvre chef de l'écho là
[Musique]
sur la place rouge je vous voyais
défiler de jeunes marins du corps de
cadets de marine de grandes statues en
tête du détachement d'honneur
le capitaine de vaisseau nicolas doze
besco commandant le corps de cadets dans
les murs de cet établissement sont
reprises les meilleures traditions
d'instruction des cadets de la marine
des fils maintenant un détachement des
meilleurs représentants du mouvement
paramilitaire et patriotique
yuna mia qui signifie jeune armée sous
le commandement de daria borisova ce
mouvement regroupe dans tout le pays
plus de huit cent mille jeunes garçons
et filles qui témoigne de leur
engagement actif
[Musique]
sur la place rouge
un régiment des troupes terrestres des
forces armées de russie leur marché est
ouverte par des officiers en cours de
formation à l'académie interarmes des
forces armées de la fédération de russie
le détachement d'honneur sous les ordres
du général alexandre romantchouk 24
commandants de groupes d'armées et plus
de 80 chefs d'armée honte a su mêler
l'arbre vaincre rennes dans les murs de
cette académie le 2000 anciens élèves de
cet établissement prestigieux sont
devenus héros de l'union soviétique et
héros de la fédération de russie devant
les tribunes défile un détachement de
l'université militaire du ministère de
la défense de la fédération de russie
sous les ordres du général vladimir
lougovoï commandant l'université
l'université c'est le principal
établissement militaire d'enseignement
supérieur à l'orientation humanitaire a
incrit forme des spécialistes dans les
disciplines politique psychologique
juridique traduction interprétation en
matière militaire à plus de 300 héros de
l'union soviétique de la russie en sont
issus des villes ensuite solennellement
sur la place rouge à l'académie
militaire aux lèvres d'intendance et de
matériel son détachement d'honneur est
commandée par le général vladimir
konovalov vain pendant la guerre les
diplômés de l'académie ont participé aux
préparatifs et au déroulement de toutes
les opérations stratégiques au niveau
des groupes d'armées et désarmé
d'accord la place rouge accueille les
élèves de l'académie militaire de
défense antiaérienne maréchal wasilewski
le détachement d'honneur et sur les
autres du général que hleb et rumine
commandant l'académie durant les années
de guerre les hommes de la défense
contre avions accomplir des missions
consistant à repousser les attaques
l'aviation ennemie
aujourd'hui l'académie forme des cadres
supérieurs pour les systèmes et complexe
de missiles sol air des filets sous vos
yeux des effectifs féminins des
établissements d'enseignement militaire
supérieur de russie ce sont des futurs
officiers de l'intendance des
psychologues interprète militaire
juriste responsable financier officier
des forces spéciales et des
transmissions
elles sont placés sous les ordres du
commandant maria vassilieva et du
capitaine svetlana ici cobas aujourd'hui
on compte plus de 40 mille femmes dans
les rangs de l'armée russe
devant les tribunes des films maintenant
un régiment des forces 0 spatiale russe
il comprend des officiers et des élèves
de l'académie aérospatiale joukovski et
gagarine
le détachement d'honneur et sur les
autres général bien najib robe un
commandant l'académie ranson ton
histoire à cette académie a formé plus
de 1500 officiers qui ont été décoré de
la plus haute distinction à savoir le
titre de héros de l'union soviétique et
de la fédération de russie
cette année la russie a célébré le 60e
anniversaire du premier vol habité dans
l'espace en l'occurrence de youri
gagarine qui étaient diplômés de cette
académie
l'académie a apporté une contribution
considérable à la conquête de l'espace
elles forment aujourd'hui des officiers
dans diverses spécialités appliqué à
l'aviation militaire et aux troupes de
guerre électronique sur la place rouge
un détachement d'honneur de l'académie
spatiales militaires à morges à skis qui
est placée sous les ordres du général
maxime penkova directeur de l'académie
ces diplômes sont ces diplômés pardon
sont des ingénieurs de pointe qui sont
affectés dans les troupes spatiales
aujourd'hui l'académie est le principal
établissement de formation et de
recherche
il faudra les spécialistes en fusée
spatiale 1
[Musique]
vous voyez maintenant le régiment des
forces navales de la fédération de
russie
ce passage commence par un détachement
d'honneur
deux marins de l'académie navale à
meyrals kuznetsova c'était tellement et
placés sous les ordres du capitaine de
vaisseau andré limengo les diplômés de
l'académie composent l'essentiel du
commandement de la marine russe le de
trente anciens diplômés qui sont devenus
héros de l'union soviétique et héros du
travail socialiste sur la place rouge
des élèves de l'école supérieure navale
à meyrals nakhimov de la mer noire qui
est basée à sébastopol où ils défilent
sous les ordres du contre-amiral
alexandre grimes kevin je devais mais
l'officier de marine à sont issus de cet
institut est parmi plus de 20 son héros
de l'union soviétique et héros de la
fédération de russie
[Musique]
devant les tribunes des piles
l'infanterie de marine qui est
représenté par 60 e unique mpri cadets
qui reconnaissent des fonderies de
marine de la flotte du nord dont le
détachement est commandé par le
lieutenant-colonel ivan slatkine la
génération actuelle des soldats de
l'infanterie de marine poursuivi les
glorieuses et traditions de défense de
la région arctique de la russie
le défilé se poursuit avec les troupes
de missiles stratégiques
le détachement d'honneur et sous les
ordres du général andré morozov vin
qu'il comprend des officiers et des
élèves officiers des cours supérieures
des établissements d'enseignement
militaire des troupes de missiles
stratégiques notamment l'académie
militaire payeur le grand et sa filiale
de la ville de cerveau korver qui fête
cette année son 80e anniversaire
les connaissances et les compétences
assimilé dans les murs de l'académie
permettent aux officiers des troupes de
missiles stratégiques de remplir nos
missions de défense des intérêts
nationaux de la russie
les diplômés de cet établissement sont
des spécialistes unique en matière
d'exploitation de tous les types de
missiles stratégiques notamment de
complexes ya ce mobile est est
stationnaire
[Musique]
des militaires des troupes aéroportées
frappe durement le sol de leurs pas
martial le détachement de l'école
supérieure générale marguelov de
commandement aéroporté deriaz année et
sous les ordres de son commandant le
colonel ruslana evdokimov les diplômés
de cet établissement figurant parmi les
meilleurs dans l'armée russe pour leur
niveau d'instruction
vous voyez maintenant défilé le 330 un
game régiment de parachutistes de la
garde de la ville de kostroma qui
appartient à la 98e division aéroportée
de détachement d'honneur et sous les
ordres du colonel au legs mais leur vin
ce régiment est le premier dans l'armée
russe à s'être vu remettre le titre
prestigieux de régiments de force de
frappe
[Musique]
la marche se poursuit avec l'institut de
protection des frontières du fsb le
détachement et ce tous les autres que
générale valérie kozlov commandant
l'institut aujourd'hui dans ses rangs
servent des petit fils et arrière petit
fils des gardes-frontières qui figurent
les premiers à faire face à l'offensive
de l'agresseur dans les tout premiers
jours de la guerre sur la place aux jeux
défilent des militaires de la 45e
brigade du génie de la garde de berlin
le détachement d'honneur et placés sous
les ordres du colonel romanowski grâce
au génie militaire des dizaines
d'opérations de défense et offensives
ont été menées à bien au cours de la
seconde guerre mondiale sur la place
rouge je vouvoyais maintenant des filets
un détachement de l'académie maréchal
timochenko de protection nucléaire
bactériologique et chimique
j'suis détachement est commandée par le
général igor emelyanov les diplômés de
cette académie servent aujourd'hui en
régiment des forces armées un
détachement des transmissions des fils
représentés par des élèves de l'académie
militaire maréchal bourgogne et laisse
les ordres du général sarrail costa rêve
commandant l'académie depuis plus de 100
ans
l'histoire un santon histoire n'a qu'à
des méformes des commandants et des
ingénieurs au profit des unités de
transmission de l'armée russe ainsi que
pour les forces armées de 40 pays
étrangers
[Musique]
devant les tribunes vous voyez défiler
un bataillon des troupes ferroviaire
elles sont représentés par 300 8e
brigade ferroviaire sous les ordres du
colonel igor orlov son commandant depuis
plus de 170 ans
les spécialistes en transport militaire
ferroviaire remplir les missions les
plus complexes dans les délais les plus
courts et au plus haut niveau sur la
place rouge défile un détachement
d'honneur de la police militaire sous
les ordres du lieutenant colonel
vitality calvario aujourd'hui la police
militaire accompli tin man d'émissions
spéciales notamment dans d'autres pays
sur la place principale du pays des
files un détachement d'honneur de
l'académie de sécurité civile du
ministère des situations d'urgence
ce détachement d'honneur et placés sous
les ordres du général victor pantchenkov
comment dans l'académie partout dans le
monde les anciens élèves de l'académie
sont reconnus comme parmi les meilleurs
en matière d'intervention sur les lieux
de catastrophe et de sauvetage de vies
vous voyez passer un détachement de la
division honneur chinsky ajouté troupes
de la garde nationale de la fédération
de russie qui est commandée par le
général de maîtrise cherepanov dit
comment dans la division
depuis le défilé de 1941 les militaires
de la division par théo prompt pour
défendre moscou et en juin 45 il se
taire devant le mausolée
les étendards et les drapeaux d unité
nazie écrasé la société dépose acte
russie est représentée par détachement
d'honneur des troupes de cosaques de
coban et de la grande troupe du don
dirigée par le général prozac nicolaï
dowload ac pendant des centaines
d'années les cosaques ont défendu le
pays natal conquis de nouveaux
territoires et protéger les frontières
aujourd'hui la tradition kozak se
poursuit la jeune génération est éduqué
dans l'esprit du service à la russie sur
la place rouge défilé des hommes du
district militaire ou veste avec à leur
tête un détachement d'honneur de la 2e
division d'infanterie mécanisée kalinin
de taman est placée sous les ordres du
général sergueï mènerait des vingt sept
divisions connu son baptême chuck en
juin 1941 dans la défense de la ville de
smolensk pour l'héroïsme a généralisé de
ses hommes
la division fut une des premières à être
distingué du titre prestigieux de la
division de la garde ses soldats
libérèrent le caucase du nord
la crimée les pays baltes et la prusse
orientale durant la guerre 34 fusiliers
furent déclarés héros de l'union
soviétique cinq chevaliers à part
entière de l'offre de la gloire toute
glace
sur la place rouge ce défilé militaire
de la 4e division blindée de la carte
entre pauvres le commandant de la
division le général-major platini rabat
ce qui est en tête de la formation
durant la seconde guerre mondiale ce
corps d'armée s'est illustré dans les
combats dans la région et donne et a
obtenu l'appellation honorifique de
contenir of sky a durant la guerre les
chartes les divisions ont parcouru du
chemin des combats de voronej à prague
les étendards de ses unités porter 23
décoration de combat subit du site et
devient fort adaptant de soixante dix
ans unissent cette célèbre division et
les cosaques
des milliers de soldats qui sont issus
de la communauté des cosaques ont servi
dans ces unités
[Musique]
sur la place rouge et défilent la 27e
brigade d'infanterie mécanisée de
sébastopol avec à sa tête le colonel
emile tri actionnant 20 commandant la
brigade heures durant la guerre les
soldats de la brigade ont participé à la
libération de l'imprimer et des pays
baltes
treize militaires de la brigade ont
obtenu les plus hautes distinctions du
pays
deux héros de l'union soviétique et
héros de la fédération de russie de son
chevalier de l'ordre de la gloire
[Musique]
le défilé des troupes alliées s'achève
par le passage des élèves sophistiqué de
l'école supérieur interarmées de moscou
l'officier qui défilent en tête et le
lieutenant colonel vadim et sakho 20 ans
s'étaient comme militaire a été créé il
ya plus de 100 ans
parmi ses premiers figurent cinq
maréchaux et plus de 600 généraux 106
diplômé de l'école ont obtenu les hautes
distinctions héros de l'union soviétique
héros du travail socialistes et héros de
la fédération de russie
de nos jours l'école est un
établissement d'ellipses réforme des
officiers pour un les unités des forces
terrestres heureux
[Musique]
maintenant les musiciens laisse le
passage on trouve peu mécanisée la
musique militaire de la garnison de
monstrueux et sous la baguette du
général major qui ma fille maya qui mena
juriste émérite de la russie
le bruit des moteurs annonce le début
que des filets mécanisée sur la place
rouge
il comprend du matériel de l'époque de
la seconde guerre mondiale des armements
modernes 190 véhicules vont passer sur
les pavés de la place rouge
baa
l'honneur d'ouvrir le défilé mécanisée
et confiée aux militaires de la première
armée de chars de la garde sous les
ordres du général sergueï qui s'est lui
ils sont à bord du char t34 85 meilleur
char de la seconde guerre mondiale
durant la guerre la première armée de
chars s'est illustré dans les combats et
apporter sa contribution à la défaite de
l'ennemi la formation de célèbres t34
est emmenée par le capitaine sergei gros
mot le défilé des armements modernes en
dotation dans les forces armées de la
fédération lucic est ouvert par le
passage des véhicules appartenant à la
45e brigades spéciales de la garde sous
les ordres du capitaine evans projet de
pôle
ce sont des véhicules blindés multi
rôles typhoon pvo
et iphone vdv équipés de modules de
télécommande
je suis un détachement du 15e régiment
de la garde d'infanterie mécanisée
schawinski faisant partie de la division
de taman sous les ordres du commandant
dimitri s'il gagne ses hommes sont à
bord de véhicules de combat d'infanterie
bmp deux équipés d'un module de combat
des régions et des véhicules lourds de
combat d'infanterie de nouvelle
génération cours gagnait 2,25 équipé
d'un module de combat et port à la
formation de la 27e brigade de la garde
d'enfants tri mécanisé de sébastopol est
composé de véhicules de combat
d'infanterie b mp3 elle est placée sous
les ordres du commandant igor matveïev
ces véhicules assure le transport et
l'appui feu des troupes mécanisées
durant le combat en toutes circonstances
la place rouge accueille une colonne de
chars de combat t-72 b3 m appartenant au
1er régiment de la garde de charger
koski qui porte le nom du maréchal
cateau cola le régime en fait partie de
la division de taman
la formation est conduite par le
capitaine racim taguiyev ce régiment est
décoré de six ordres militaires
récompensant les faits de guerre de ses
soldats viennent ensuite les chars de
combat t80 bvm équipés de turbomoteurs
ses chars sont en dotation à la 200e
brigade d'infanterie mécanisée
la formation est sous les ordres du
capitaine alexandre corniche et cette
brigade protège les frontières de la
russie dans la zone arctique
voici veut dire une formation de
matériel blindé de type les plus récents
en dotation de la 27e brigade de la
garde d'infanterie mécanisée de
sébastopol sous les ordres du chef de
bataillon constantin au sol 7
ce sont des chars de combat et 80 mb pro
rif et des quatorze harmattan
[Musique]
la place rouge accueille des armements
des troupes de missiles et d'artillerie
des forces armées de la fédération de
russie
les premiers défilés sont les missiles
balistiques de courte et moyenne portée
à haute précision de tir iskander m
d'autant la 112e brigade de la garde de
leurs six l'étendard de la brigade porte
cet ordre militaire y compris l'ordre
alexandre nevsky ses décorations
récompense la bravoure de ses soldats
lors de la libération de novorossiisk
franchissement d'une haie près de loder
et de la prise de berlin
viennent ensuite mais lance roquettes
multiples moderniser tornado s dotation
à la 439e brigade de la garde de père
écope
[Musique]
la formation est conduite par le
capitaine du veniamine dryates keane les
militaires de la brigade perpétuent les
traditions des légendaires katusha
l'artillerie des forces terrestres est
représenté par une colonne d'obusiers
automoteurs de 152 mm le stress est qu à
leeds as v équipant la 236e brigade
d'artillerie qui défilent sous les
ordres du commandant et vitali klitschko
système moderne de conduite de tir et
les performances techniques poussées
confère à ces systèmes d'artillerie une
haute précision et une grande puissance
de prière
[Musique]
la place rouge accueille une des unités
de défense aérienne des forces
terrestres
le détachement est commandée par le
commandant sergueï lavrov cette unité
présente des systèmes d'armes solaire
d'or m2 appartenant au régiment de la
garde de tarnopol faisant partie de la
quatrième division contenir austère et
des systèmes d'armes sol air hook m3
appartenant à la 53e brigade anti
aériennes de berlin ces armes modernes
sont capables de faire face aux frappes
aériennes de nature différente
viennent ensuite les systèmes d'armes
solaire et force aérospatiale les
premiers à défiler sont les systèmes
antiaériens missiles canon 26s du 600
12e régiment de la garde de kiev sous
les ordres du commandant seguin
chichkine l'unité a été récompensé par
cinq clics aux rations militaires pour
des faits de guerre
voici venir les systèmes d'armes anti
aériens et anti missiles s-400 triumph
en dotant le 93e régiment de la garde
qui sous les ordres du commandant andré
geim sauve grâce à ses performances le
système d'armes s 400 triumph dispose
d'une avance qu'elle fit qualitative
évidente sur les autres systèmes aériens
de même catégorie
il est capable de détruire tous les
moyens existants d'attaqués aériennes et
les missiles balistiques
devant les tribunes passe différents
matériels des troupes aéroportées
ce sont des véhicules de combat
dmd 4ème de nouvelle génération équipant
la scion 6e division aéroportée de la
garde bazert tous là ils défilent sous
les ordres du commandant dennis bouche
copé ces véhicules sont inégalés au
niveau de leur vitesse de déplacement de
la puissance de feu et des altitudes de
parachutage
humain ni mes parents
minimes d'autres
viennent ensuite des véhicules blindés
multi rôles moderniser btr mdm
raccrochera appartenant au 137e régiment
aéroporté de la garde
basée à raison ils sont conduits par le
capitaine il douce altenberg
voici venir une formation de lance
roquettes multiples modernise et au ce1
à qui tire des projectiles thermobarique
ils équipent la première brigade mobile
des troupes de protection nbc
ces véhicules défilent sous les ordres
du capitaine dimitri dimitrov
[Musique]
sur les pavés de la place rouge s'avance
une colonne de véhicules de pose de
mines de transport et de rechargement
qui font partie du brio du système de
minage à distance isdn ils sont en
dotation à la première brigade le gêner
brest berlin les véhicules défilent sous
les ordres de l'ue du lieutenant-colonel
dimitri l'oubli 10 nov
ce système deux ménages à distance est
doté d'un équipement de pointe qui
permet de poser des champs de mines les
plus complexes
la place rouge accueille les drones
terrestre d'appui feu orange neuf sous
les ordres du commandant alexeï
kukushkin ces véhicules nous fait preuve
de leur efficacité lors des opérations
en république arabe syrienne leur
armement permet d'accomplir sur le champ
de bataille
toutes les missions propres aux unités
interarmes
[Musique]
la police militaire des forces armées de
la fédération de russie présente les
véhicules blindés haute protection des
grandes capacités de franchissement
tigre est une patrouille et typhoon
ayew ils défilent sous les ordres du
commandant pavel maximum ces véhicules
sont utilisés par la police militaire
dans les opérations de combat et pour
accueillir accomplir des missions
spéciales devant les tribunes défilent
les véhicules de la garde nationale de
la fédération de russie sous les ordres
du commandant alexeï celle vers ce sont
des véhicules blindés tigre patrouille
et orale destiné à la conduite des
opérations dans des conditions
difficiles
au chili
la place rouge accueille une colonne
mécanisée de troupes de missiles
stratégiques
elle est composée de robes mobile de
lancement de missiles balistiques
intercontinentaux ya recours de temps la
54e division de la gare ils sont sous
les ordres du lieutenant colonel romano
le système balistique yaars est capable
de franchir toutes les forces anti
missile existantes
les unités doter de missiles le système
d'armes gars sont le fleuron du
groupement mobile d force de guerre
le défilé mécanisée s'achèvent par des
véhicules blindés de combat d'infanterie
à rob ranck qui présente les étendards
de toutes les armées des forces armées
russes
c'est le début du défilé aérien
le défilé aérien est ouvert par trois
hélicoptères lourds will we 20,6 le
groupe est guidé par le commandant igor
czekaj avait suivi un groupe de cinq
hélicoptères multi rôles 1008ha mt chat
le groupe est sous les ordres du
lieutenant colonel nicolas sarkoy m
viennent ensuite des hélicoptères
d'attaqué millet mi 35m mi-24 la
formation est amené par le
lieutenant-colonel guennadi lollia
cauvin vous voyez maintenant cinq
hélicoptères d'attaqué de reconnaissance
kamov ka 52 alligator la patrouille est
sous les ordres du colonel vassili clert
cinco la place rouge est survolée par la
patrouille acrobatique berkut avec le
royal et ses hélicoptères mil mi 28n
chasseur de nuit
la patrouille équité par le lieutenant
colonel edouard cause à chuck dans le
ciel de moscou une formation de trois
avions de transport et liu xin il 76 mde
sous les ordres du commandant mikhail
krasnov 20 les commandants andreï bykov
et ivan d'orphée yèvre font une
démonstration de ravitaillement en vol
du bombardier stratégique du palais b 95
par l'avion de ravitaillement et légumes
78 de ravitaillement vols de bombardiers
stratégiques supersonique du pôle hervé
160 lui permet d'accomplir des missions
dans des régions les plus éloignées du
club
les avions sont pilotés par le
lieutenant-colonel ruslan khamitov et le
commandant michael michelin
vient ensuite un autre bombardiers
stratégiques supersonique qui relève 160
piloté par le commandant after petrenko
il est escorté par quatre chasseurs
d'aviation paktika
[Musique]
et voici une patrouille de quatre
chasseurs multirôle de génération 4 + +
chocolate 35s sous les ordres du
lieutenant colonel à l'excès jusqu'à
repas
le défilé aérien continue avec le
passage de bombardiers tactiques
moderniser jusqu'au 24
m sous les ordres du lieutenant colonel
germann anna cave
la patrie suivante est composé de
chasseurs mig 30 1 k armés de missiles
hypersonique qu'il gèle la patrouille
est amené par le commandant alexeï
malachenko
[Musique]
et voici une formation de sa soeur de
cinquième génération je cueille 57 sous
les ordres du lieutenant colonel
vladimir voltchkov va
dans le ciel de moscou une formation
tactique qui comprend 10 appareils de
combat ce sont des bombardiers sur cauet
34 des chasseurs chico et 30 sms co et
35 sur les autres du colonel iouri grid
sayan confus
au dessus de la place rose le fameux
diamant de copines cas cette formation
est composée de chasseurs su qu est 30
mm x 29 qui équipe les deux célèbres
patrouilles acrobatiques les russkie
vitiazi preux russes et l'estrie j
martin et la patrouille est sous le
commandement du colonel andré alexeyev
le défilé aérien se termine par le
passage sous le commandement du
lieutenant colonel jadir mandat sauf de
six avions d'attaqué au sol ce qu est
25e mls dans le ciel un panache des
trois couleurs du drapeau russe s'est
pas trop bien et conduit par un
lieutenant-colonel l'admirent mort
d'hasan 20
vas y on ne va pas là bas
le défilé s'achève par le chant la
victoire est toujours jeune interprété
par la musique militaire
[Musique]
m
abba
[Musique]
précieux
bianchi
la musique militaire quitte la place
rouge solaire à dieu de la femme ce là
bas le défilé militaire prend son terme
un célébrant le 76e anniversaire de la
grande victoire aura gloire aux anciens
combattants de la grande guerre
patriotique haut rhin bonne fête à tous
les citoyens de la russie pour un
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
non
on
[Musique]
oui
je
[Musique]
on
m
[Musique]
on
que les enfants
[Musique]
c'est vrai
non
[Musique]
je
m
[Musique]
non
moi
[Musique]
oh
on
non
[Musique]
oh
hu
[Musique]
vous
non
[Musique]
on